i
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález en el
salvador policías y militares fueron
sacados a las calles luego de que fuera
decretado el estado de excepción las
medidas son unas de las respuestas ante
los hechos de violencia el sábado pasado
fue decretado como el día más violento
en la historia con 62 asesinatos la
mayoría de las víctimas de pandillas el
salvador tiene una larga historia de
grupos de crimen organizado que se
enfrentan contra las fuerzas de
seguridad y también entre otras
pandillas para controlar el territorio y
las rutas del narcotráfico en
centroamérica
justamente la seguridad y una postura
firme contra la violencia contra las
pandillas fue una de las promesas más
fuertes en la campaña del hoy presidente
en allí bukele pero los sectores de la
oposición en el salvador también
diferentes ongs y organismos
internacionales entre otros han
criticado al presidente salvadoreño y
creen que las medidas son exageradas
bukele no ha dudado en responder como
mejor lo sabe hacer es decir a través de
'twitter' veamos veamos por ejemplo este
texto estos vividores de las ongs
internacionales dicen velar por los
humanos pero no se interesan por las
víctimas sólo defienden asesinos como si
disfrutaran ver los baños de sangre
dígame cuántos miles de pandilleros van
a llevarse para que los traten como
reyes allá en hablándole a las personas
de la comunidad internacional
el presidente también ha sido muy
directo con las pandillas y con los
integrantes que ya han sido capturados y
a quien él dijo que reducirá sus
raciones de comida y les decomisará
todas sus pertenencias esto fue lo que
dijo tenemos 16 mil home voice en
nuestro poder aparte de los 1000
arrestados en estos días les decomisamos
todo hasta las colchonetas para dormir y
les en racionamos la comida y ahora ya
no verán el sol paren de matar ya a
ellos les va lo van a apagar también
en esa misma línea le hablo con firmeza
también a la comunidad internacional que
pocas veces respalda a la mayoría de sus
acciones la otra cara de la moneda es el
miedo entre los salvadoreños debido a la
violencia veamos por ejemplo lo que dijo
el presidente y si la comunidad
internacional está preocupada por sus
angelitos vengan y traigan les comida
porque yo no le quitaré presupuesto a
las escuelas para darle de comer a estos
terroristas vamos a racionar la misma
comida que se da ahora y de ahí comerán
los nuevos también
dentro de las restricciones que trae el
estado de excepción el mandatario hizo
aclaraciones obviamente a través de
'twitter'
y servicios religiosos eventos
deportivos comercio estudios etcétera
pueden seguirse realizando normalmente a
menos que usted sea pandillero o las
autoridades lo consideran sospechoso sin
embargo si habrá algunos cierres
focalizados y temporales en algunas
zonas
bueno lo cierto es que el presidente
bucl en su forma en su idea en su estilo
está cumpliendo con una de sus labores
que es defender a los salvadoreños
preservar la integridad territorial y
garantizar la seguridad pero a qué costo
hoy en el debate de france 24 hacemos
foco en el salvador estado de excepción
o de abuso para analizar este tema hemos
invitado entonces en la ciudad de san
salvador está con nosotros guillermo
gallegos él es diputado de la asamblea
legislativa de el salvador y también
está con nosotros abraham ábrego ls
director del litigio estratégico cristo
sal ustedes también nuestros
televidentes se pueden participar en
este debate con todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas pueden hacerlas a través
de las redes sociales ustedes ya la
conocen estamos en facebook en instagram
y en twitter estamos como france24 bajo
ese anti logo que es mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas
relacionadas con este tema comienzo
entonces con el diputado gallegos en la
ciudad de san salvador le doy la
bienvenida al programa diputado gracias
por acompañarnos
desde su opinión está el presidente bucl
excediéndose en sus labores como
presidente en pro de garantizar la
seguridad del pueblo salvadoreño que
piensa usted
bueno muchas gracias y muy buenas tardes
después definitivamente que no el
presidente bukele está utilizando el
mecanismo legal que establece nuestra
constitución que es la implementación de
un régimen de sección invocando la
causal cuando hay grave perturbación del
orden público es que ha sido totalmente
anormal en menos de 72 horas que hayan
sido asesinados casi 70 salvadoreños
incluyendo una niña de nueve años y ocho
años pero y todo atribuido a las
pandillas o maras o terroristas como
fueron declarados por la sala de lo
constitucional de nuestro país en una
media medida urgente en la madrugada del
domingo recién pasado y en base a la
constitución
67 diputados de 84 que somos en total
representando a cinco partidos decidimos
aprobar este régimen de sección que
tiene como fundamento principal la
suspensión de garantías constitucionales
entonces
por mi parte puedo decir que no hay
ningún abuso hasta este momento después
de haber sido implementado no hay
denuncia alguna que diga que la policía
o el ejército se está extralimitando lo
que sigue abierto es que ya más de 1600
pandilleros capturados en lo que va del
régimen de selección y le hago la misma
pregunta a nuestro otro invitado abraham
en la ciudad de san salvador también
bienvenido al programa y la misma
pregunta como punto de partida para este
debate está el presidente bucl
excediéndose de sus capacidades y poder
para poder garantizar la seguridad de
los salvadoreños a raíz de este brote de
violencia de los últimos días
señor abraham creo que tienen en
silencio el micrófono pero ahora sí lo
vemos perfecto gracias por la invitación
un saludo al diputado gallego a nuestro
juicio si hay un mal uso del mecanismo
que establece la constitución que es el
régimen de excepción que es un mecanismo
de emergencias constitucionales donde
hay que darles alteraciones al orden
público y que debe ser usado en
situaciones realmente de bastante
gravedad de falta de control del estado
y lo que a nuestro juicio no no no
engloba esta emergencia que se ha dado a
partir del viernes con el incremento de
homicidios
hay que recordar desde el 1996 que ya
había habido algunos intentos por
incrementos por el régimen de excepción
la sala de lo constitucional desde
1996 han señalado que el sol incremento
de homicidios
y no es justificante ni en mí ni es
adecuado a las condiciones de las
situaciones que establece el artículo 29
en esa línea y nosotros sí nos preocupa
y nuestra solidaridad con las víctimas
ahora entendemos que ya se llevan más de
80 personas asesinadas por la
delincuencia y nos parece que el estado
debe asumirlo pero no parece que haya
mecanismos creados en la legislación
penal y otra legislación y perfectamente
en el estado puede usar esos mecanismos
y recurrir a una medida tan quizás tan
grande y tan drástica como la suspensión
de derechos constitucionales abraham
debido al panorama que se está viviendo
en el salsa en el salvador la gran
cantidad de muertes de los últimos días
cómo hacer equilibrio entonces entre
esta violencia que se estaba viviendo
como reducirla como garantizar entonces
la seguridad para los ciudadanos en cómo
actuar diferente a tener mano dura
contra estas pandillas cuál es su
opinión
a mi juicio a veces hay una dicotomía
como que
para combatir la criminalidad y proteger
a la población es necesario violar
derechos humanos y yo no estoy de
acuerdo creo que lo que se respeta el
debido proceso eso no afecta en ninguna
forma que haya una posibilidad de una
justicia efectiva sin embargo hemos
visto mucho uso de la mesa' es de
bastante retórica de la mano dura
y a veces con fuerza de que se va a
combatir la criminalidad pero a veces el
problema es que las investigaciones las
evidencias no son tan fuertes y en lo
que termine en este tipo de medidas son
en detenciones bastante masivas pero que
muchas veces no logran resultados para
esclarecer la verdad porque se caen en
procesos judiciales porque no reúnen lo
lo mínimo requisito entonces yo creo que
lo que se requiere salvador es realmente
una política integral efectiva y creo
que hay herramientas que ya tiene el
estado para para controlar este tipo de
situaciones
y hay que recordar que los incrementos
de homicidios en el pasado han sido
derivados de rompimiento de treguas como
pasó ya en la tregua anterior en
pandillas donde a raíz de que el ayer
nos rompió esa tregua y un incremento
acelerado es decir no es una situación
normal de elecciones sino que hay otros
factores que podrían estar generando
este este incremento guillermo en paso
preguntarle a ustedes allí en la ciudad
de san salvador ya vemos hay muchas
críticas hacia el presidente bucl e por
la forma como ha manejado el tema de
seguridad que era uno de los temas
abanderados de su campaña electoral
cuando aspiraba a la presidencia y ha
sido criticado por la mano dura pero
aquí vemos que hay un nuevo estallido de
violencia en las cifras así lo
demuestran son contundentes y el miedo
de la población también es evidente la
mano dura entonces tampoco está
sirviendo por parte del gobierno para
mitigar la violencia
bueno la implementación del plan control
territorial es el eje principal en
materia de seguridad del presidente o
que l no sólo implica
la expresión también estaba está la
prevención con la construcción de
centros de
esparcimiento de entretenimiento en las
diferentes zonas donde hay
el libro de pandilleros el salvador
venía de experimentar hasta días
consecutivos de no tener o visible
algunos varios días sin domicilio y
nosotros pensamos que este accionar de
las pandillas en el país no solamente un
accionar de un reflejo de las pandillas
nosotros creemos que hay y otros
sectores interesados en querer ocasionar
este tipo de situaciones justamente
cuando venían inversores inversionistas
perdón al país que estaban llegando al
país gente muy importante que he puesto
su vista en nuestro país para invertir
comienza esta ola
se ha capturado recientemente a un
transportista que al parecer que el
aviso y los también con las pandillas y
está llamado a que se desemboque como lo
decía el licenciado agregó que él para
mí sí es una grave perturbación el hecho
de que el tres días muera 80 ciudadanos
comunes y corrientes que van a trabajar
si es una grave perturbación y así lo
hemos considerado los diputados son
raíces del régimen de sección se ha
logrado capturas
cuáles son las sur cuáles son las
garantías constitucionales que se han
suspendido bueno la primera de ellas es
ampliar la detención administrativa o
sea la detención que los días que la
fiscalía tiene para presentar al juzgado
en nuestro país se vota entre el día y
hoy se ha empleado a 15 días porque
tiene una explicación estas capturas que
de casi 1.600
pandilleros diligencias entre días va a
ser prácticamente
se requiere toda una serie de
preparación para
siempre el el hecho de que se puedan
concentrar
personas en
sí perdón es que se me está extendiendo
mucho diputado y el tiempo es muy corto
y necesito abarcar en muchos temas que
usted estaba explicando unos puntos
importantes de lo que significa este
estado de excepción
es claro este primer punto que nos
explica quiero preguntarle entonces a
abraham en este estado de excepción y
éstas prolongaciones en los términos de
tiempos como nos estaba explicando el
diputado son violaciones de derechos de
cuáles derechos estamos hablando que se
están violando o estos anuncios o
llamados que ha hecho el presidente bucl
a través de su cuenta en twitter
diciendo que le va a racionar la comida
a los que están presos que les va a
quitar sus pertenencias incluso hasta
las colchonetas a eso es a lo que
ustedes se refieren o se refiere la
comunidad internacional que hay
violaciones de derechos humanos
si efectivamente yo creo que a veces el
presidente hace declaraciones en twitter
y otros funcionarios que no van con los
estándares hay que recordar que las
personas que están recluidas sean
condenadas o procesadas
no significa que pierdan su derecho a la
alimentación y la responsabilidad estado
con su cuido entonces la a veces hay
declaraciones de ese tipo que realmente
violentan cualquier mínimo estándar y el
respeto a los derechos humanos en
general y la preocupación quizás con el
régimen de excepción es que la forma en
que está planteado es muy amplia y se
aplica a cualquier ciudadano y puede dar
lugar a
arbitrariedades por ejemplo
la fiscalía en un comunicado decía que
podía ser cierres temporales y
focalizados en algunos sitios del país
pero sin embargo hay que recordar que el
decreto no suspende la libertad de
circulación
que podría ser digamos la
posibilidad en caso de cierre porque
afecta a la libertad de tránsito pero
ese derecho
claro vendido por el decreto pero
realmente en la medida si la están
aplicando cercos entonces creo que hay
que revisar y hay un llamado al diputado
para que la asamblea revisa realmente si
se está cumpliendo el decreto según
respecto al marco que puede dar lugar a
estos abusos que por querer combatir la
criminalidad se lleven de encuentro a
personas que realmente no tienen nada
que ver y que claro es la preocupación
de la comunidad de internacionalidades y
de diputado que puede responder a este a
este comentario que hace el señor
abraham estas preocupaciones que hay que
se puede decir desde el área de la
asamblea legislativa salvadoreña
bueno lo que sucede es que se están
implementando los
regímenes de selección focalizados en
aquellos lugares donde se tiene
determinado que existen grandes
concentraciones de pandilleros y que por
mucho tiempo la misma población que vive
y ha solicitado la presencia de la
policía con el régimen de excepción se
acordona se cierra todo el área para que
nadie puede estar y salir porque
desgraciadamente hay que decirlo los
pandilleros han permeado tanto a la
sociedad salvadoreña que gente que se
hace pasar por vendedores niños o
personas que no parecen pandilleros son
los encargados de transportar les el
dinero de la extorsión de llevar lejos
sacar armas por eso se vuelve necesario
que aún a pesar de la situación que pasa
están enfrentando personas que no son
pandilleros es importante poder los
revisar poderlos resultar para que no se
aproveche este tipo de personas que
están lejos de ir atrás para que puedan
transportar les algún
y al [__] todos los partidos entonces
yo creo que si puedo asegurarte que hay
mucha aceptación de estas pérdidas
actualmente en el país y lo que debemos
de garantizar yo coincido con conectado
abrigo es garantizar los derechos un
claro diputado aquellos que no son
pandilleros pero el momento no hay
ninguna denuncia de algún ciudadano del
sector que diga mire a nosotros estudio
los derechos humanos con el régimen de
60 diputados el mandatario bukele
también a través de su cuenta de twitter
escribió que están tratando de descifrar
esto fue un mensaje que puso durante el
fin de semana que están tratando de
descifrar quién está financiando esto
refiriéndose a este estallido de
violencia que hubo durante el fin de
semana y estos asesinatos que hubo
principalmente en la capital hay
intereses ocultos en detrás de estos
ataques hay intereses de desestabilizar
el gobierno del presidente bucl quienes
podrían estar detrás financiando este
tipo actos que ha denunciado así el
presidente de buques
bueno yo puedo decir que ha sido muy
revelador que tanto el partido arena
como el fmln
han faltado con las pandillas en un
momento determinado incluso una fórmula
presidencial del partido arena negocio u
otro a cambio de dinero con las
pandillas el fmln hizo una tregua con
las pandillas la cual nos causó muchos
problemas al país hay sectores
opositores al gobierno como yo
mencionaba este empresario del
transporte que está siendo procesado
también entonces uno no puede descartar
yo por eso vuelva a existir el accionar
de las pandillas en los últimos días
luego accionar aislado y que pueda tener
algún tipo de apoyo respaldo de partidos
políticos o de sectores que están
interesados en desestabilizar
al gobierno
entiendo entiendo su punto diputado
abraham
recientemente el gobierno del salvador
criticó a otros organismos
internacionales como por ejemplo la o y
la cdh porque
fueron las que patrocinaron esta llamada
tregua que hubo entre las pandillas y el
gobierno salvadoreño que sólo desde el
punto de vista del gobierno sirvió para
que las las pandillas se fortalecieran
se reorganizarán se armarán y les
permitió acumular más recursos dinero
estrategia para poder combatir y hacer
este tipo de incursiones a gran escala
como son las que se están viviendo en
los últimos días allí en el salvador
porque
el presidente critica a estos organismos
internacionales por fomentar este tipo
de treguas cuando sería un punto de
partida tal vez para una negociación
piense que esa ha sido una discusión de
nosotros desde la sociedad civil siempre
hemos impulsado que la
solución del problema estructural de
violencia inseguridad en el país tiene
que nacer a partir de diálogos que es
muy diferente a negociaciones donde se
puedan de alguna manera cometer delitos
porque los tipos de treguas que hemos
conocido y tienen que ver por ejemplo
con el apoyo de la familia porque a
cambio de votos
o de por ejemplo impedir a los votantes
ir en
partidos adversarios entonces ahí hay
mucha tela que cortar con los tipos de
tregua que se han hecho eso no
si habrá de la de las pandillas
arco legal en esa línea porque había hay
varios proyectos en la asamblea
legislativa del día deberían buscarse
eso es muy diferente a treguas donde se
negocian otras cosas más bien es un
diálogo
constructivo para buscar una salida a la
violencia de las pandillas y a buscar la
reinserción de aquellos
jóvenes o personas que están
involucrados en la violencia y que
quieran digamos rehabilitarse y
reinsertarse en la sociedad creo que
este es el tema que para mí para
nosotros debería como impulsarse
pero es muy diferente a las treguas que
ha habido yo creo que es un tema de
tregua hay que hacer las investigaciones
hay investigaciones incluso en el
gobierno actual periodísticas sobre
posibles treguas creo que hay que
aclarar eso hay proceso abiertos y yo
creo que hay que rendir cuentas de
cualquier gobierno sobre este tipo de
tregua es muy diferente a generar una
política de reinserción y de diálogo de
sectores sociales que creo que es muy
necesario en el salvador diputado que
puede decir usted al respecto cuál sería
el mecanismo más indicado para empezar a
superar estos temas
y que el salvador pueda dejar de lado y
cerrar el capítulo de la existencia de
estas pandillas estas maras que han
crecido a lo largo de los últimos años
bueno personalmente yo creo que un
pandillero terrorista no tiene
readaptación no tiene reinserción en el
país han habido diferentes programas
incluso la unión europea por ejemplo
invirtió una gran cantidad de euros en
tratarlos de reinsertar a la sociedad
poniéndoles panaderías que hicieron
estos bueno lo que hicieron fue matar a
todos aquellos otros panaderos que no
eran mareros para quedarse en el negocio
entre otras cosas yo creo que un
terrorista un pandillero no tiene
reinserción porque a hacer el sicariato
el asesinato y la extorsión una forma de
vida para mí y yo quiero proponer que en
diferentes ocasiones como diputado de
que debería de aplicarse la pena capital
o la pena de muerte para este tipo de
sujetos porque difícilmente sean
infectados tantas cosas pero yo creo que
él
internada a ellos les permea para poder
ser reinsertar de hecho hay pandilleros
en eeuu que han sido ya condenados a
muerte pandilleros ladrones
desgraciadamente y han sido condenados a
muerte porque los crímenes que cometen
las atrocidades que prometen finalmente
11 no lágrima en películas de terror o
de películas que muestran cosas muy muy
muy difunda bless para poder superar
diputados ya que usted menciona eeuu
justamente el pasado mes de diciembre el
departamento del tesoro de estados
unidos impuso sanciones a dos
funcionarios del gobierno del salvador
acusándolos de estar negociando con la
ms-13 y con barrio 18 un supuesto
acuerdo para poder llegar a una tregua a
cambio de apoyo político para el partido
político del presidente en equipo que le
crece el el partido nuevas ideas
el gobierno de eeuu ha criticado mucho
al salvador por esto que se puede decir
desde el gobierno de estas acusaciones
bueno
hasta el momento aquí en el salvador no
hay una investigación sobre estos dos
funcionarios que han sido señalados por
los eeuu
y eso es lo importante sería que si los
estados unidos llega a tener este tipo
de informaciones que hagan al hagan
llegar pero simplemente lo señalan y
dejan así como abierta la
posibilidad de que se puede interpretar
que pruebas no han presentado no han
mandado
y hasta el momento para como digo no hay
una investigación sobre todo los
funcionarios que siguen teniendo sus
cargos y que el presidente por los
márgenes de los cargos
abraham en línea con esto que le estoy
preguntando al diputado de estas
posibles acusaciones por parte de eeuu
de una supuesta negociación a cambio de
apoyo político por parte de las
pandillas también eeuu acusó a la
administración del presidente bucl en
2020 de brindar incentivos financieros
también a las pandillas
a cambio de garantizar que el número de
ataques o de incidentes de violencia
bajarán para el presidente poder
presentar unas mejores cifras y un poco
de tranquilidad a la ciudadanía son
acusaciones que hace a washington no las
estoy diciendo yo
desde el punto de vista de ustedes de
derechos humanos de corrupción y de
investigaciones de estos temas hay algo
en camino de investigación hay
evidencias de estos posibles pagos de
esta ayuda financiera de esta
negociación por bajó de la mesa por
parte del gobierno y las pandillas
y mira lamentablemente en el salvador y
nosotros criticamos esa medida que tomó
la asamblea el primero de mayo
se destituyó al fiscal y el legítimo a
nuestro juicio original y a los
magistrados de la sala constitucional
en mayo de 2000
en mayo 2021
y luego también se
hizo para nosotros es
no ofrece una garantía independencia en
la
investigación de este tipo de casos
señalados de hecho nosotros teníamos
conocimiento que el fiscal que fue
destituido aunque fue cambiado el
primero de mayo tenía abiertas varias
investigaciones de corrupción a partir
de avisos de la misma 16 pero que y
hemos preguntado hasta ahora el fiscal
actual y si le ha seguido no tenemos
respuesta entonces realmente el tema de
la garantía de independencia para decir
que el sistema actual judicial va a
lograr investigar este tipo de caso es
bien limitado a nuestro juicio debería
rendirse cuentas o sea creo que una
acusación de este tipo de grave e
incluso es malo para los funcionarios
porque quedan como señalados y yo creo
que deberían abrirse a rendir cuentas a
dar toda la información o las
explicaciones pero dejar también que se
investiguen igual que ya hay procesos
abiertos
de treguas en un anterior el gobierno
pero de que esos señores o si han
caminado y hay gente procesado incluso
detenida por el tema de la tregua
entonces lo mismo tiene que ser con el
actual gobierno si hay una acusación
debe ventilarse y muy transparente en el
aire porque creo que son acusaciones muy
graves que ha hecho y que aparecen en el
informe de el departamento de estado de
eeuu
diputado algo que llama la atención
desde fuera de las fronteras del
salvador es la popularidad del
presidente bucl enormemente popularidad
entre los salvadoreños tiene el
mandatario a lo largo de estos meses en
los que ha gobernado este país
centroamericano pero recibe muchos
señalamientos por parte de la comunidad
internacional por parte de las
organizaciones internacionales a qué se
debe esta popularidad a qué se debe este
buen respaldo por parte de los
salvadoreños y esta negativa o esta
imagen o percepción negativa por parte
de la comunidad internacional en
diferentes áreas
bueno el presidente busque él es
productor
el surge y es el electro producto del
hartazgo de la gente con los dos
partidos tradicionales que gobernaron
los últimos 30 años a nuestro país el
cansancio
y quizás ya el hasta aquí lo llevó a ser
presidente y precisamente compitió por
con mi partido por gana un partido
realmente pequeño pero que logró
pues ganar las elecciones dos años
después como lo saben todos el pueblo le
ratifica y le endosa ese apoyo
otorgándole una gran cantidad de
diputados así a su partido la nueva idea
yo creo que es lo que él ha logrado
capitalizar ha hecho cosas realmente que
nadie había hecho muchos la gran mayoría
le reconoce como este honor el tema de
la pandemia a pesar de tener una sala de
lo constitucional y una asamblea en
contra y bueno la gente se siente
identificado y si la gran mayoría de
desarmador y de los organismos
internacionales bueno él tiene su estilo
de gobernar de comunicarse utiliza mucho
las redes sociales y en presidente
diferente de los otros
organismos internacionales se quedaban
callados no decían nada por amor porque
que algo podía pasar en esta
empresa su manera entiendo el diputado y
abraham llegamos ya la recta final del
programa quiero que hagamos las
conclusiones comienzo por abraham
preguntándole qué va a suceder con esta
espiral de violencia que está viviendo
el salvador y que el gobierno comenzó a
contrarrestar sacando a la policía y al
ejército a las calles y que ya empieza a
dar algunos resultados dependiendo de
cómo uno lo mire puede ser positivo o
negativo el balance lo hace cada quien
pero que cree usted que iba a suceder se
meterá el salvador en una espiral de
violencia largo o esto cortará y
simplemente se da una anécdota más del
gobierno de boc él
bueno la bueno yo creo que yo esperamos
que esta crisis que haya surgido por
incremento de homicidios tiende a bajar
a tener control nos preocupa sobre todo
la atención de la víctima que ha
generado este este tema de violencia
igual que las que ya hay en el salvador
producto de la violencia histórica y
nosotros sí creemos que esperamos que no
se siga prorrogando este tipo de medidas
como el régimen de excepción el
presidente bucl es y creo que subió un
tweet donde un poco advertía que iban a
prorrogarla y nosotros de nuestra
nuestra valoración es que
el estado tiene las herramientas para
hacerlo pero que puede ser más
puede ser peor la medicina que la
enfermedad porque el problema de régimen
de excepción se presta a abusos y
nosotros lo que vamos a estar haciendo
como organización es documentando
informando sobre
el uso del realmente excepción y cómo
puede generar abusos porque creo que no
nos preocupa este esperamos que ojalá
que pase
esta crisis de violencia y se logre que
señala un sesgo de justicia para para
indagar y estaremos atentos a los
informes que ustedes puedan presentar en
torno a estos posibles abusos que puedan
llegar a presentarse en los próximos
días diputados su conclusión qué va a
suceder en el salvador
bueno lo que esperamos y lo que todos
quisiéramos es que pueda detenerse y
poner atrás prisión a la gran mayoría de
pandilleros si es necesario la
constitución nos permite prorrogar por
30 días más el régimen de de sergio
nosotros lo haríamos está dando
resultado y creemos que después en la
aplicación de este tipo de herramientas
constitucionales en una respuesta
inmediata contundente a la captura y al
sacar de circulación clara esto implica
también gais y coincido con habrán no
solamente es esto también hay que
implementar otras políticas criminales
para poder sostener un tema social es lo
que tanto añoramos los salvadoreños
después de claro casi 30 años de
conflicto armado más lo de las pandillas
vemos que en un país que no hemos gozado
de paz social azul que en 30 35 años
diputado gallegos y abraham ábrego les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
haber analizado para la audiencia de
france 24 este
que concierne al salvador estos días
recientes de violencia en este país
centroamericano y también para ponernos
en contexto en torno a las políticas que
se están implementando allí precisamente
para contrarrestar estos hechos de
violencia ustedes muchas gracias por la
sintonía continúen dejando todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]